welcome back everyone to my round six
recap of the abu dhabi masters
tournament
i just finished the game about 10
minutes ago so uh things are still very
fresh
adrenaline is slowly
drifting down but
very intense game and let's get into it
i was playing a player by the name of
raza madavi
from iran and he's about uh i think 14
maybe 15 years old um young talented
player
and i found a lot of games online of his
so i um i was able to predict opening in
this game which was a bishop b5 czech
sicilian
and um i should note uh yesterday was a
rest day so i had a lot of time to
prepare
and um i mean there was only one game
today at 5 pm so
several hours before the game i was
reviewing my lines
and i prepared pretty deeply into a line
that we ended up going into
after traded bishops my opponent goes
for the so-called marathi bind setup
and let me make sure
oh let me make sure i'm hiding notation
but i guess i'm also leaking the fact
that uh i was preparing for for my
opponent's leeches
um leachates account and maybe i'll
leave this open because there is a um
an interesting tidbit
after the line that we went into um i
mean this is all standard opening theory
uh we got to
this position
and my opponent played knight b3 here
and if we see based on his leech ass
games he has played knight b3 once
before
and uh it's one of the best moves in the
position
and uh thankfully i was prepared for
this move before the game
so let me hide
the
notation here
and um
try and avoid any any spoilers
but knight b3 was played uh there are a
few other moves like he's played b3 a
lot in like blitz and bullets but b3
walks into takes takes and b5
and this is one of the threats of asics
as i do want to take and play b5
so there's another main line here queen
d3
which i think is considered to be also
one of the more testing variations
and then i had
a ton more prep from this position uh
there were some lines i was preparing
uh like 30 35 moves deep um so we didn't
go into any of it and maybe i'll save
the prep for a future game
but uh yeah knight b3 was played and i
went for uh knight e5
and now c5
and i'll actually leave this to show
because um this is not an anonymous
account like his username is tamo jerry
it was pretty easy to look up so he has
played this game once uh it was a
blitzer bullet game let's see
this is a blitz game from three months
ago
so i looked at this game before the
round
and i followed exactly what his opponent
played knight c4
take take
and then rook c8
and uh here he finally deviated from the
game
uh rather than taking the pawn
he played rook 81
i was actually prepared for uh kind of a
cool trap if he were to take
i would take with the queen
and then say oh no i'm getting fort
and if he does fork this is already i
think
close to winning for black after knight
d5
and uh yeah i was prepared further here
it takes takes
takes
rook fe8 rook f2
and then uh key move bishop takes c3 uh
deviating from his game
and if we got to this position i would
be very happy
and the engine should say that black is
uh yeah close to winning
so
uh we didn't go into that
and we got a fresh position rook
to d1
and just to give a sense of like the
thoroughness of my prep i was also
prepared for this move and i played
queen c7
just getting off the file of the rook
and i remember when i looked at this
position a few hours before the game i
thought it was weird that um
the engine says this is okay for black
because at first it doesn't look that
great given the pawn is isolated
and uh white has very good control over
the d5 square
but i looked into this position a bit
with the engine and came up with some
interesting ideas
a few of which i managed to play in the
game
so rook c1 was played
and i play rook to e8
and one of the
main ideas for black in this position is
to break with d5 eventually
especially because the rook is aligned
with the white queen
this pawn is currently pinned
but it's not so easy to do because
there's also alignment
on the c file
so we played a couple more moves rook
fd1 get the queen off the file
and here i think my opponent played the
first
i don't know if it's a clear mistake or
dubious move of the game
but rook d2
which looks very natural perhaps
intending to double up on the d d-file
but i think this move was a little bit
negligent of
of one of my ideas
now when he played rook d2 the first
move that came to mind was d5
which is probably a playable move
but then i realized there's
a different idea in this in this
position
and it's actually a pretty rare type of
tactical idea
but the key thing to be aware of is
the queen
and both rooks are aligned on this
diagonal
so it'd be really really nice if i could
somehow
threaten bishop h6
and there is one way to do that uh let
me hide notation now so i don't spoil
anything further
the only way to do that is to play queen
f8
so this is essentially a retreating
attacking move because now i have a
clear threat of bishop h6
and the
the strength of bishop h6 is not that
i'm necessarily winning material because
white has f4
but uh the whole point is to provoke
white to play f4
after which the pawns are a bit softer
and they'd be easier to exploit
so um
yeah so queen f8 it's it's a nice
tactical idea that will lead to some
positional advantage for black
and after this move uh things were going
very well i played bishop h6 provoke f4
played b5
because white played f4 now e4 pawn is a
lot more vulnerable and i'm already
threatening pawn b4 to chase and play
the knight and win the pawn
so he played a3 here
and now i keep adding pressure rook c4
attacking the pawn from multiple
directions
and he plays rook d4
trying to neutralize
i play queen e7 continuing the pressure
and my queen served its purpose on f8 to
support this move so it can now go back
and i was really happy with this move
because not only am i applying more
pressure along e-file
but there's uh some nice ideas of
potentially going for knight g4 queen h4
or to play queen a7
to exploit the diagonal the a7 g1
diagonal and white has to be really
careful here
not to lose immediately like for example
if he takes the rook i take and then
let's say 92 i think knight g4 is
already winning for black because if the
queen leaves this diagonal queen a7 is
pretty much lights out for white uh king
f1 knight h2 is mate and king h1 there's
going to be some fun windmill
so
that didn't happen
instead he played pawn g3
which i think
is probably the best try for white in
the position
solidifying the pawn and giving some
luft for the king as well
so i play knight g4 he plays queen e2
and then i played queen a7 when i played
this move i thought for some reason i
thought i would be winning material but
i just missed his next move king to g2
which is a
a pretty simple way to kind of deal with
the pressure in the position
i should note that uh yeah after queen
a7 i leave the knight hanging but if he
were to take it
i wouldn't take the rook right away i
would play bishop g7 and i'm pretty sure
black will be
winning the exchange here because
there's just no
no way to resolve the pinned rook on d4
so king g2
was a resourceful move from white and
i took
take
and play f5
so white is definitely not out of danger
yet just because
all the pressure is still very much
alive in the position
and uh yeah the e pawn is pinned the
knight is hanging my knight is now
defended so i'm threatening to take on
d4
so he plays queen d2
and i play bishop g7
so yeah the bishop served its purpose on
on h6
to provoke f4 so it returns to the long
diagonal
and he played knight f3
and in this position i played a very
committal move
but during the game i was happy with it
i decided to
give up my dark squared bishop
and generally this is just not a move
you want to play
unless it leads to
some clear advantage and i played bishop
takes c3
thinking that i'd be winning a pawn
and i didn't win a pawn after pawn takes
takes takes takes
and
oh there's actually a funny line here
which um
actually if we go back
before i played bishop takes c3 there's
actually
a really nice calculation
that involves
kind of a temporary queen sacrifice for
black to get a completely winning end
game
so i'll go ahead and show the line but
it's essentially what we got in the game
and here he played knight d4 but if he
were to play queen d5
which looks like it just wins back the
pawn
i can just play king g7 white will take
and now
queen to f2
and for a very brief moment
it looks like white is
still holding on uh but there's a really
nice move for black in this position
and perhaps i gave a bit of a clue
earlier but it's to take on h2
and say oh no my queen
but then win it right back and uh this
would be a winning end game for black up
a pawn and winning another pawn and
probably winning a third pawn too
so
i'm also realizing there's queen f1 here
although i don't know if that works
after king h4
because my king is also vulnerable so
uh anyway that could have been a funny
line but
that didn't happen because after takes
takes he played knight to d4
and i was feeling really really good
here
having just won a pawn
and uh it seems like white's not getting
much compensation for it
on top of that
i realize that the time stamps aren't
here but uh
he he was falling pretty low on time he
had maybe about five minutes around this
point
and i had perhaps 15 to 20 minutes
so things were looking very good for me
i played queen c5 relatively quickly
and then he played a4
and i think in this position i got a
little bit careless
and i played the move queen d5
uh thinking oh i'm so clever threatening
a discovered check to to win white's
queen but i just completely overlooked
his next move queen e2
and then all of a sudden
my extra pawn might be coming off the
board given my knight is attacked and b5
is attacked three times
so i think queen d5 was just a very
careless move on on my part
um after the game he told me i probably
should have played queen c4
which now that i'm looking at this
this just looks really really good for
black because i prevent queen a2 check i
control the e2 square
and if takes takes
everything looks to be under control for
black like knight f6 and d5 coming
so
somewhat of a regret not playing queen
c4 but after queen d5 i still thought i
was playing for a win after queen e2
i play e3
into g1
but then around here i realized it's
really not so simple
and there's some concrete problems to
address given my knights attacked my
ponsil attacked
and e3 pawn looks a bit overextended and
when i played the e3 i thought i could
go for this move knight f2
but i don't think this works
like even though i'm threatening maiden
one with queen h1 he can take
and now queen h1 there's king f2
uh i was looking at knight h3
forcing king f1 queen h1
king e2 takes
i don't think this leads to much after
let's say king e1
and my knight's just really out of play
like queen h1 the king's gonna zigzag
to safety
and it could be my king that uh
is just very naked in the position
so i didn't go for this
and instead i played
queen h5
uh defending the knight
but also ensuring that i'm pressuring
the h-pawn
and then after takes takes i think here
he played a very good move h4
and uh
yeah here i realized that
whatever advantage i had
i pretty much slipped away
and i was also getting low on time here
but the game keeps going i played knight
f6 offering a queen trade
and for some reason when i played this
move i thought he was going to take
completely forgetting that my e3 pawn
just drops
so sometimes this happens in chess where
like where your advantage slips and then
it can just turn into
a whole downward spiral and um
yeah once he took on e3 i realized that
i should just hunker down
and uh not make things worse
so i play queen g4
uh preventing queen e6 jack
and pressuring the pawn
he plays king to g2 i should note that
if he takes the pawn here then i have
some annoying checks and it should be
fine for black
so after king g2
play queen d7
and then he plays f5
and i think somewhere around here maybe
after queen g4 had offered a draw but he
declined it
and uh it was clear that he was trying
to go for more than just to draw
but after it takes queen g5 king f7 he
takes
looks like my king is a bit vulnerable
but i have queen to c6
and queen takes c3
and yeah there's no mating attack for
whites
my knight does a good job of controlling
some key squares
and he took on d6 if he plays queen g7 i
just have this move
and everything is fine for black
um so he took on d6 and
i believe yeah i believe he offered a
draw in this position
and i was getting really low on time i
think we both had maybe around two
minutes here
and i agreed to the draw um but then
right after i agreed to it he told me
that i could have played on uh he told
me i could have played this
takes check here and quindy one
and i was looking at lines like this but
i really didn't think i had much winning
chances here
being
down a pawn i mean i know black hasn't
made in one threat
but there's gonna be some knight check
like knight c7
and we were analyzing this briefly like
king f7 and then white has
probably king h2 or
although king h2 there's queen
c2 winning the
knight maybe i could have gone for this
um
anyway now i think it's time to look at
the engine and see
the key moments in this game perhaps the
key mistakes
is this actually better for black no
ah just king g2 here
yeah white's white's fine the knight's
defended
uh i have some checks but nothing more
um
so i want to go back further because
just to verify
uh the blunder
oh wow
a4 is just an equalizing move
now i really thought i was like much
much better here but
so did i go wrong earlier
wait let's go back to this position
i played bishop g7
and we just played the top oh no
oh he should have taken with the queen
queen takes e3 is a difficult move to
play
ah my mistake was queen c5
and kudos to him for finding the only
equalizing move a4
so he played this move with like three
minutes left maybe four minutes left
so i should have played
knight f6
ah just prophylaxis like holding the
position together ensuring the
the knight and pawn are no longer so
loose
a4 i can take it
okay so i had
i had a chance this game i mean it
wasn't completely winning
um
it felt like a really nice game up until
this uh
up until the point that he
kind of switched the momentum but
um
it was a fun one i'm not too
disappointed even though it felt like i
had chances i think a draw is a still a
very solid result
and my opponent's been having a really
good tournament um i think he's
he's been and drawn a handful of players
much higher than him
so i guess i'm another
other victim or another half victim
but uh yeah the tournament keeps going
uh that was round six so i'm still at
fifty percent three out of six
tomorrow will be around seven
and this is a nine-round tournament
and uh
maybe what i'll do right before the
video ends
i'll go ahead and share the standings of
the tournament
i've been linking this in every video
the the leachat broadcast but if you go
to
this page and then click results
you can see
the overall results and sorry if uh
the layout's off but we can go to
ranking list
oh the round six is currently underway
but we can see the the standings after
round five
uh
and we see yeah ray robson is actually
he wasn't clear first uh going into this
round i think he drew von forrest
so go ray we uh yeah we both traveled
to abu dhabi from st louis
we can also see irene is doing very well
i think she won this round too
so
i'm definitely cheering on my friends
and if you scroll down far enough
you can find my name
i'm currently
yeah currently
i i was at 50 i'm still at 50
so
as usual i'll leave a link to the
broadcast the pairings and standings
in the video description
and if you made this far
thanks so much for watching
and i'll see you in the next video